let's do a few more problems that bring
together the concepts that we learned in
the last two videos so let's say we have
the inequality 4x plus 3
is less than
negative 1. so let's find all of the x's
that satisfy this so the first thing i'd
like to do is get rid of this 3 so let's
subtract 3
from both sides of this equation so the
left hand side is just going to end up
being 4
x these 3's cancel out that just ends up
with a zero no reason to change the
inequality just yet we're just adding
and subtracting from both sides in this
case subtracting that doesn't change the
inequality as long as we're subtracting
the same value we have negative one
minus three that is negative 4
negative 1
minus 3 is negative 4
and then
we'll want to let's see we could divide
both sides of this equation by 4.
let's divide both sides of this equation
by 4. once again when you multiply or
divide both sides of an inequality by a
positive number it doesn't change the
inequality so the left-hand side is just
x
x is less than negative four divided by
four
is
negative one
x is less than negative one or we could
write this in interval notation all of
the x's from negative infinity
to negative one but not including
negative 1 so we put a parenthesis right
there
let's do a slightly
well i'll do a slightly harder one let's
say we have 5 x
is greater than 8x
plus 27.
so let's get all our x's on the
left-hand side and the best way to do
that is subtract 8x from both sides
so you subtract 8x
from both sides the left-hand side
becomes 5x
minus 8x that's negative 3x
we still have a greater than sign we're
just adding or subtracting the same
quantity to both sides these eight x's
cancel out and you're just left with a
27.
so you have negative 3x is greater than
27. now to just turn this into an x we
want to divide both sides by negative 3
but remember when you multiply or divide
both sides of an inequality by a
negative number you swap the inequality
so if we divide both sides of this
by negative 3
both sides by
negative 3 we have to swap this
inequality it will go from being a
greater than sign to a
less than sign and this is a bit of a
way that i remember greater than is that
the left-hand side just looks bigger
this is greater than if you just imagine
this height that height is less than is
greater than that height right there
which is just a point i don't know if
that confuses you or not this is less
than this is this little point is less
than the distance of that big opening
that's how i remember it but anyway
3x over negative 3 so anyway so now that
we divided both sides by a negative
number by negative 3 we swapped the
inequality from greater than to less
than and the left-hand side the negative
3s cancel out you get x is less than 27
over negative 3 which is negative 9 or
in interval notation it would be
everything from negative infinity to
negative 9 not including negative 9. if
you wanted to do it as a number line
it would look like this
this would be
negative 9 maybe this would be negative
8 maybe this would be negative 10 you
would start at negative 9 not included
because we don't have an equal sign here
and you go all the way everything less
than that all the way down as we see to
negative infinity let's do a let's do a
nice
a nice hairy problem
so let's say we have
i don't know let's say we have
8x
8x minus five
times four x plus one
is greater than or equal to negative one
plus two times four x
minus three now this might seem very
daunting but if we just simplify it step
by step you'll see it's no harder than
any of the other problems we've tackled
so let's just simplify this you get 8x
minus let's distribute let's distribute
this negative 5. so let me say 8x and
then distribute the negative 5 negative
5 times 4x is negative
20x negative 5 when i say negative 5 i'm
talking about this whole thing negative
5 times 1
is negative 5
and then that's going to be greater than
or equal to negative 1 plus 2 times 4x
is 8x 2 times negative 3 is negative 6.
and now we can merge these two terms 8x
minus 20x is negative
12x
minus 5
is greater than or equal to we can merge
these
we can merge these constant terms
negative 1
minus 6 that's negative 7
and then we have this plus 8x
left over now i like to get all my x
terms on the left hand side so let's
let's subtract 8x from both sides of
this equation
so let's subtract 8x from both sides of
this equation
from both sides i'm subtracting 8x
this left-hand side negative 12 minus 8
that's negative 20.
twenty x
minus five
once again no reason to change the
inequality just yet all we're doing is
at simplifying the sides or adding and
subtracting from them
the right hand side becomes
this thing cancels out 8x minus 8x
that's 0. so you're just left with a
negative
7.
and now i want to get rid of this
negative 5. so let's add 5 to both sides
of this equation
let's add 5 to both sides of this
equation
the left-hand side you're just left with
a negative
20x the five and the these fives cancel
out
no reason to change the inequality just
yet negative seven plus five
that's negative
2.
now we're at an interesting point we
have negative 20x is greater than or
equal to negative 2.
if this was an equation or really any
type of even inequality we want to
divide both sides by negative 20 but we
have to remember when you multiply or
divide both sides of an inequality by a
negative number you have to swap the
inequality so let's remember that so if
we divide
this side by negative 20 and we divide
this side by negative 20. all i did is
took both of these sides divided by
negative 20 we have to swap the
inequality the greater than or equal to
has to become a less than
or equal sign
and of course these cancel out and you
get x is less than or equal to the
negatives cancel out 2 over 20 is 1 over
1 over 10. and if we write it in
interval notation you would the upper
bound would be 1 over 10. notice we're
including it because we have an equal
sign less than or equal so we're
including 1 over 10 and we're going to
go all the way down to negative infinity
everything less than or equal to
1 over 10. this is just another way of
writing that
and just
for fun let's draw the number line
let's draw the number line right here
this is maybe zero
that is one
one over ten might be over here
one over ten everything less than or
equal to one over ten so we're going to
equal we're going to include
we're going to include the one tenth and
everything less than that is included in
the solutions and you could try out any
value less than one over ten and verify
that it will satisfy this inequality